est ce que quelqu'un a quelque chose
contre les fournissent s'il vous plaît
au secours les fourmis léger tout ça
c'est une catastrophe
les tomates sont bouffés c'est archi
bouffer heureusement heureusement qu est
ce qu on va se faire à midi une
aubergine
c'est de l'aubergine heureusement que
les fourmis pour l'instant n'ont pas
attaqué des aubergines et non pas à
tacler non plus et alors ça c'est quand
même super important mais petit ça
ya quelqu'un quelque chose contre les
fourmis s'il vous plaît
quant aux
tiens
j'ai préparé votre anniversaire je me
suis qu'on pourrait faire des jeux
rigolos sur le tour
on pourrait faire la marelle on pourrait
faire une belle aux prisonniers sur le
côté
[Musique]
pourquoi
ok un excuse moi
non est ce que vous avez fait des
blagues
[Musique]
elle est bannie pas
comment [ __ ] la honte en deux minutes
coucou victoire
est bien ta crème un compte sur toi
ta maman tu embrasses d'accord
oui
mais ta crème 1 surtout en mettant sa
peau un patienter allergies
on
non